salut et bienvenue sur le premier
concours de casse-tête de ma chaîne
youtube et peut-être même le dernier ce
qu'il a fallu trouver des gens qui
veulent faire un concours de casse-tête
et on vous a un peu forcé à venir non
c'est ça voilà
ils sont en tétanique concours de
casse-tête ça veut dire qu'on a réuni
tous nos plus beaux casse-tête quand je
dis nos plus beaux casse-têtes c'est pas
les miens c'est ceux de chez nkd puzzle
vous les voyez sur ma chaîne depuis
longtemps le mécanique masse a été le
premier que j'ai réalisé sur la chaîne
et bien ça va être nos supports pour
toutes les étapes de ce concours quatre
étapes première étape ça va être des
énigmes le premier ou la première qui
donne la réponse et sélectionner pour la
suite deuxième étape vous venez déjà
plus que 5
vous n'êtes pas amis entre vous ok vous
êtes concurrent ne restera plus que 5
qui viendront faire l'un de ces deux
casse-têtes c'est vous qui choisirez
c'est les deux plus simples vous aurez 4
minutes pour le résoudre et le but c'est
pas de l'ouvrir évidemment 4000 c'est un
petit peu chaud c'est on va voir où en
est votre logique au bout de 4 minutes
de là il nous restera plus que trois
personnes les trois meilleurs
ces trois personnes vont revenir et vont
s'attaquer à la scriptum les deux
meilleurs sur la scriptum s'affronteront
sur les profs finales de la mécanique
mars mais version application une
application qui a créé nkd vous en
reparlerai tout à l'heure donc la
personne qui gagne le concours de
casse-tête repart avec 1000 euros tout
le monde attend une blague derrière non
c'est vrai c'est vrai je ne serai pas
tout seul vous l'avez compris par cette
vidéo j'aurai un deuxième mentaliste à
mes côtés j'invoque Charlie heads
c'est incroyable les applaudissements te
aident à l'invocation ouais ça me fait
pop si vous connaissez pas Charlie head
c'est un mentaliste que j'ai découvert
sur l'article tu es sur toutes les
autres plateformes mais à la base j'ai
acheté des couleurs dessus tu as
commencé non j'ai commencé par YouTube
mais oublions cette période on a tous
des périodes sont sur Youtube j'ai
tellement envie de retrouver ces vidéos
est-ce que vous êtes prêt à vous
confronter à ces casse-têtes incroyables
mais juste avant il y a les énigmes vous
êtes prêts pour ça alors c'est parti
pour l'étape 1
tu veux commencer tu ouvres le bal allez
une personne rentre dans une salle elle
ouvre la porte et elle le voit Roméo et
Juliette mort sur le sol deux indices il
y a de l'eau sur le sol il y a du vert
et il y a un chat qui sort au moment où
elle ouvre la porte que s'est-il passé
le chat est sauté sur le l'aquarium et
ces deux poissons qui s'appelle Roméo et
Juliette c'est un Oui bien joué
ou pas
dit oui quand même c'est quoi ton prénom
cristal moi j'en ai une qui est
relativement rapide alors soyez bien
concentrés on me trouve à la fin du
matin et seulement deux fois dans
l'année
la première levée c'était toi j'allais
dire le M c'est pas grave ok on le
sélectionne c'est faire plaisir
j'adore les chaussettes donc c'est une
énigme sur les chaussettes un homme se
réveille dans le noir complet il ouvre
son tiroir dans son tiroir il y a six
chaussettes noires 4 rouge et bleu
combien de chaussettes devra-t-il
prendre pour être certain d'avoir au
moins une paire de noir donc deux
chaussettes noires
les chaussettes version rapidité
toujours dans le tiroir de mon bonhomme
il y a 49 chaussettes noires il y a 49
chaussettes blanches combien il doit
prendre de chaussettes pour avoir au
moins une paire de la même couleur
ouais c'est 3 c'est assez joué entre
vous deux vous savez ok faites un
chifoumi Shifumi le premier qui gagne
attention
[Musique]
merci beaucoup pour cette première étape
on va passer à la deuxième tout de suite
[Musique]
ils sont 5 ils vont avoir 4 minutes
chacun pour résoudre l'un de ces deux
casse-têtes et faire les plus grandes
avancées possible et juste avant de
commencer je vous présente quand même
ces casse-têtes et nkd puzzle si vous
suivez la chaîne de pied un petit moment
vous m'avez vu résoudre pas mal
d'excellents et magnifiques casse-tête
en bois comme la mécaniquema la scriptum
cube de luxe ou encore c'est mon préféré
l'architecteo tous ces casse-têtes ils
viennent donc de chez nkd puzzle une
boîte de casse-tête 100% made in France
qui depuis 2019 n'arrête pas de grandir
parce qu'ils font que d'évoluer en
termes d'esthétisme de créativité de
mécanisme c'est une dinguerie ils ont
lui-même trois médailles d'or au
concours Lépine parce que ce sont des
inventions c'est incroyable et on aime
particulièrement la qualité de chacun
des casse-tête qui produisent et les
correspondabilité de l'ensemble et
aujourd'hui vous allez découvrir une
nouvelle facette de nkd puzzle puisque
c'est le volet un peu innovation puisque
cette entreprise basée à Lodève a créé
la surprise en créant Unima benator Rome
c'est le premier jeu mobile 100%
français dédié au casse-tête 3D dispo
bien sûr sur Android et sur Apple le jeu
des gros casse-têtes et des magnifiques
casse-têtes qui ont fait la réputation
des nkd puzzle comme ça vous voyez là
autour de la table évidemment je vous
mettrai des liens dans la description
pour télécharger l'appli et vous faire
ces casse-têtes là parce que c'est ça
qui est bien en fait c'est qu'il y a ok
c'est magnifique d'avoir ces objets en
main ou de les construire si vous en
avez jamais fait et si vous êtes un peu
impatient vous pouvez télécharger
l'application et même rocher un petit
peu dessus c'est très agréable aussi
donc on y reviendra durant ce concours
parce que la finale ce sera sur
l'application mais pour l'instant on
garde les cassettes en main c'est ça tu
préfères la mini steampunk ou la Silver
City de luxe la deuxième 4 minutes pour
aller le plus loin possible à partir du
moment où c'est en contact avec tes
mains je lance le chrono ça marche
tu as une solution Charlie haute que la
GT contre un mur c'est rapide moi j'ai
une petite astuce en général quand je
rejoins un casse-tête
principe d'inversion je vais réfléchis à
tout ce qui n'est impeccable de faire tu
trouves des solutions ok ce qui marche
avec les problématiques de la vie
exactement tu as fait deux mouvements
qui est très très joli celui-là et là
maintenant celui-ci je l'ai jamais
résolu sur ma chaîne en plus donc vous
avez pas de coût d'avance en voyant mes
vidéos petite indice non
[Musique]
vraiment ça c'est un gros indice cette
phrase elle est elle est terrible quand
elle te dit bah il y a plus qu'à
l'ouvrir
il peut pas te donner meilleur indice
que il y a plus qu'à l'ouvrir plus qu'à
l'ouvrir
bravo
[Musique]
une ouverture bravo cristal tué
peut-être sélectionner pour la suite en
tout cas c'est pas mal
la pression à tes collègues tu dis je
suis en train de se content
Lucas tu as fait ton choix le deuxième
casse-tête celui du fond ok attention je
vais mettre un chrono qu'est-ce que tu
crois tu as 4 minutes seulement je vais
pas te mettre de pression mais il a été
ouvert au coup d'avant je te dis pas en
combien de temps peut-être telle info
peut-être pas tu es prêt Lucas je suis
prêt c'est un goût
alors ça si je peux te donner un indice
c'est un cube si facile
les gens abandonnent à partir de là tu
peux encore abandonner si tu veux encore
trop tôt
je vais un peu saturé ton cerveau en
tournant autour de toi s'il y a pas de
souci je peux mettre un peu de contact
physique des fois ça t'empêche de
réfléchir un petit peu ça va tu as l'air
à l'aise là ouais ça va ça va pas de
souci
et ça n'a pas l'air de l'embêter on va
peut-être monter un niveau n'hésite pas
surtout juste je mets mes mains devant
tes yeux n'hésite pas un peu compliqué
ok je fais à l'aveugle il est si à
l'aise comme cette position j'ai été
faire
voilà ok c'est bon suffisait de me
regarder en fait j'inspire les gens
c'est à peu près la moitié du casse-tête
ça c'est une vraie indication tu as
mangé quoi hier soir
à ces questions inutiles il est quelle
heure actuellement
il a été très malin parce que comme il a
repéré qu'il avait fait les mêmes
mouvements pour les quatre premiers
qu'il avait mis un peu de temps dès
qu'il en a trouvé un autre il a
réappliqué à tous les autres c'est pas
mal du tout
[Musique]
greg c'est parti est-ce que tu veux la
mini punk où est-ce que tu veux la
Silver City je vais prendre la mini punk
s'il te plaît
bravo Julien
[Applaudissements]
c'est celle qui est sur l'application
exactement
j'ai sous les yeux je me suis rendu
compte que c'était la même du coup c'est
fair-play bien joué on se rejoint à
Baltard
top c'est top on est parti
c'est un TOP après tu peux le reposer
pour te dégourdir les doigts avant si tu
peux tu es pas un mec bavard quoi
je suis un peu monotage comme mec ça
dérange pas si je prends ta main gauche
juste pour te faire un petit colding
globalement je transpire des mains je
suis désolé
quand je réussis ok globalement tu es
aussi quelqu'un qui préfère être heureux
que triste c'est correct à Yohan
absolument je vais avoir besoin de ma
deuxième main surtout que depuis tout à
l'heure le temps était arrêté ah c'est
sympa
on atteint bientôt la première minute
donc tu as tu as à peine 25% du temps
écoulé tu as fait des belles avancées
d'une manière générale dans la vie on
voulait te féliciter pour ça a une
minute 40 je reviens dans ce
déstabiliser il te reste donc 25
secondes pour elle tu sais que le pire
pour moi quand je fais des casse-tête
c'est quand il s'ouvre et que j'ai pas
compris pourquoi et là je peux tout
repartir à zéro en mode ah non j'ai un
somme terrible
c'est un succès
ok merci
attention Corentin tu veux une
information tous les casse-têtes ont été
ouverts
[Rires]
on a deux mouvements défectueux déjà
très efficace de mouvement en 30
secondes c'est pas mal sachant qu'il y
en a
128e
Corentin quelle heure est-il après toi
en ce moment je suis arrivé à 14h il
doit être 15h12
15h13 c'est pas mal excellent il est
capable de tu n'as aucun bonus pour ça
c'est vraiment un bonus de style combien
de doigts derrière ta tête Corentin
actuellement de lever ou de lever de
lever 3 pardon très très chaud
je m'assois
[Musique]
tant qu'il décide de faire machine
arrière dans le casque
alors il revient en arrière
il reste 20 secondes Corentin 10
secondes mon ami
en fait
le temps était coulé Corentin mais
effectivement tu étais un amour de la
fin un moment donné franchement tu n'as
pas démérité on se revoit tout à l'heure
mais à la toute fin les trois
sélectionnés pour l'étape suivante sont
grec avec un temps de 15 secondes
cristal avec deux minutes 15 et Yohan
avec deux minutes 27 c'est parti pour
l'étape du script
la troisième étape tu n'as pas 4 minutes
mais 5 minutes 3 2 1
moyennant 500 euros en rétrocommission
je te donne la première apparemment
c'est non alors c'est quand tu veux 3 2
1 Go
il te reste plus qu'une étape non je
rigole
je vais faire un petit peu comme toi
Fabien
exploration ça c'est peut-être de la
chance
et après on commence à se poser des
nains cette histoire
tout le monde ne voit pas que
je revis au travers lui mais bugs
dans les casse-têtes tu as vraiment des
élans de compréhension tu vois ok ça
bouge c'est bon je fais d'un puis après
tu es bloqué alors tu cherches à moi tu
commences à opérer des choses OK puis
après tu commences à avoir des
hypothèses que tu testes qui
fonctionnent plus ou moins bien
quand même des symboles ok 1 2 3 4 5
c'est le nom de ok
non
les petits des petits verrous pour pour
des hypothèses grec à la moitié de ton
temps donc
est-ce que tu voudras savoir qu'en 2
minutes ce seront écoulées oui 2 minutes
se sont écoulés
sur cette chaîne Youtube qui a eu la
même phrase à un moment donné de dire
mais c'est relou
très très sympa je pense il vient de La
Rochelle non absolument
[Rires]
[Musique]
ça n'a jamais été
techniquement on peut jamais répondre
franchement à ces questions c'est
potentiellement faisable en 5 minutes
mais c'est assez étonnant ah ok déjà on
voit qu'il y a des infos là
donc le 1 il y a 2 1 il y a un deux il y
a un 3 il y a un 4 mais il y a pas de 5
ce que tu dis il y a des choses vraies
et des choses fausses
sur les épaules du gars
il te reste tu as fait la moitié du
temps à partir du temps on va te laisser
rentrer dans ton d'accord
[Musique]
bien un avis est-ce qu'il est avancé ou
est-ce qu'il est pensé à dernière minute
je peux te donner un indice les 9 bâtons
ont une position précise en gros ça ça
t'intéresse pas tant que trouver la
bonne position de chacun des bâtons une
minute
oui il y a pas qui sont les cristal te
font pas trop de moi quand même
ah mais non mais j'ai changé des trucs
sur les petites
le 1 alors là le symbole c'est donc on
va dire c'est un A et un 3
[Applaudissements]
on arrive tous à cette étape
le temps passe une vitesse folle pas de
pression maîtresse 5 secondes
5 4
2 1 ne pose pas sur la table Greg merci
beaucoup on se revoit tout à l'heure au
moins pour le récap des scores ou en
finale te laisse retourner derrière mon
bon ami et je vais vous donner les
résultats enfin quelques-uns les
concurrents se sont affrontés sur la
scriptum cube ça c'est la version Deluxe
c'est celle que j'avais fait sur la
chaîne qui était magnifique et marketé
etc on leur avait pas mis cette version
là aujourd'hui parce que j'avais peur
qu'il a reconnaissent et qui puisse se
rappeler la vidéo et la toute première
vidéo le tout premier bijou que j'ai
touché de chez MKD c'est la
mécaniquement et c'est là-dessus qui
vont s'affronter pour la finale mais pas
avec l'outil directement avec une
version qui vous est directement
accessible la version sur leur
application qui est incroyable et qui
vient de sortir je vous en parle tout de
suite vous le disais de la réalité au
virtuelle il y avait qu'un seul pas
quelqu'un qui a des puzzle à franchi
avec l'application c'est toujours le
même principe ce sont des casse-têtes
sauf que là c'est en 3D et c'est sur
leur téléphone mobile ou en l'occurrence
dans la vidéo sur iPad que les joueurs
vont devoir résoudre ces casquettes ce
sera aussi l'occasion de voir si les
joueurs sont plus rapides sur le virtuel
que sur le réel de voir s'ils
appréhendent de la même manière
l'exploration les phases de tests etc je
suis très curieux de voir ça en tout cas
je trouve l'application géniale et bien
faite et ça peut permettre aussi pour
des personnes qui sont pas trop
sensibilisés au casse-tête déjà de s'y
mettre et de découvrir et peut-être
après à terme d'avoir envie de tout ça
je vous mets plein de gains dans la
description parce que je sais que il y a
des pages facebook qui sont dédiées il y
a plein de choses comme ça ils sont des
challenges entre les gens qui ont
l'application vous avez tout ça en
description vous allez voir une très
jolie liste maintenant on passe à la
finale
cristal tu as 10 minutes pour aller le
plus loin possible non pas physiquement
sur l'application
cristal c'est parti dans 3 2 1 final
Go c'est pas parce que tu l'as fait que
je m'en souviens évidemment et je l'ai
fait il y a très longtemps parce que
c'était la
peut-être c'est le premier vraiment gros
que vous avez sorti il me semble la
mécanique
ouais c'est ça peut-être que je vais le
faire en même temps que toi Christelle
et je serai nettement motivé je n'ai pas
1000 euros à gagner
est-ce qu'on te pique au casse-tête
Charlie est-ce que ça te donne envie
d'essayer des Castets du coup
honnêtement je pense que j'ai un concept
que je vais faire sur Youtube ce sera
des vidéos où je résous des casse-têtes
pas mal avec une cam qui vient du haut
comme ça et ta grosse tête pour pas
mal il y a pas de musique
donc là il y a une pièce qui a bougé une
pièce qui a bougé je vais faire la même
chose sur un j'ai l'impression que ça ça
bloque donc il faudrait
j'ai déjà ça je recherche ce qui bouge
d'autre alors est-ce que tu as
l'impression d'avoir commencé quelque
chose ou pas du tout
tu télécharges l'appli tu pourras avoir
des indices ou les zones qui sont
touchables je t'ai tout désactivé pour
le moment parce que c'est une finale si
tu le télécharges pour chez toi sur tous
les casse-têtes qui sont disponibles sur
l'application tu peux activer les
indices pour avancer dessus et
d'ailleurs tous les casse-têtes que tu
as vu aujourd'hui sont sur l'appli tu
t'approches de la moitié de ton temps tu
as fait grand chose c'est aussi
l'histoire de ma vie
j'ai pas fait les phases ça c'est le
mien
j'ai pas vu
j'étais opéré que même dans la version
réelle je crois qu'il y a une phase j'ai
mis genre 2 minutes à me rendre compte
qu'elle existait parce que sinon
ça serait plus agréable si vous y jouer
chez vous mettez le son vraiment oui oui
mettez le son chez vous
à bouger trois choses en tout cas
[Musique]
il te reste 3 minutes 30 ok est-ce que
tu veux savoir le temps que qui s'est
écoulé ou pas encore
merci
Charlie c'est le petit personnage est
terrible il est vraiment invité pour ça
c'est faisant des vidéos ensemble
je vois pas ce qu'elle débloque je
comprends pas ah c'était peut-être ça
quand même de l'iPad bonjour
mouvements
le fait de pas l'avoir dans les mains ça
c'est quand même assez complexe
au moins on n'a pas besoin de dire il ne
faut pas forcer
c'est lui que j'ai débloqué et je vois
pas ce que ça débloque
ok j'ai demandé combien de temps
30 secondes
c'est faux c'est une blague en fait il
reste 10 secondes de plus que 3 minutes
en fait de temps qu'on se le dise
maintenant
j'ai débloqué les deux là
une étape supplémentaire
[Musique]
c'est ton dernier mot Jean-Pierre mais
je sais que tu t'appelles Yoann en vrai
oui absolument pas mal il y a des
petites accélérations etc
très bien le gagnant ou la gagnante de
cette incroyable concours de casse-tête
je peux être un peu beaucoup non c'est
pas mal moi je trouve
à la cinquième étape et Crystal tu étais
à la troisième étape donc ça c'est pas
joué non plus quand même à grand chose
Yohan un chèque de 1000 € offert par
Fabien Lucas
merci beaucoup et évidemment un cadeau
hors du commun de place pour mon
spectacle au Palais des Glaces si tu
veux venir avec grand plaisir merci à
vous tous d'être venu pour tourner cette
vidéo ce concours casse-tête encore une
fois n'hésitez pas à venir sur des
autres tournages vous voulez venir sur
un tournage il y a un lien dans la
description pour vous inscrire et on
vous contacte quand on tourne dans votre
région dans la description vous avez
aussi trouvé tout ce qui concerne une
carte de puzzle c'est-à-dire
l'application évidemment mais toutes les
choses que j'ai cité sur eux leur site
internet etc et juste en dessous vous
allez voir tout ce qui concerne Charlie
head c'est moi donc chaîne Youtube
Instagram Tik Tok adresse postale numéro
de téléphone non non ça c'est bien merci
à Fanny à Magda d'avoir préparé cette
vidéo avec Denis et Loïc et tout le
reste de l'équipe vous avez tous les
crédits dans la description évidemment
pensez à vous abonner ça fait plaisir
activez la cloche également c'est
important bien sûr à venir voir mon
spectacle à découvrir ton livre
également qui sort le 5 octobre éditions
cerveau et celui des autres j'ai volé la
chaîne de Fabien je termine cette vidéo
jusqu'à la dernière seconde il a raison
prenez soin de vous à très bientôt Ciao